we say no more blah blah blah no more
exploitation of people and nature and
the planets no more exploitation no more
blah blah blah
no more whatever they're doing inside
there
oh she cursed no more blah blah blah i
want an oompa loompa daddy i want it now
like joe biden when asked about greta
thunderberg and all this nonsense i just
i'll never get over it i'll never get
over the old people
who are actually charged with balancing
the competing interests and then
never watch what they say watch what
they do
actually act like rational human beings
when it comes to say pumping gas because
people need gas you get in their cars
and go to work and such i'll never get
over the old people humoring this
you old man
why aren't you doing what i say
you you bastard what no more blah blah
blah
i i i understand what you're saying and
also um i would like to sniff your hair
i don't want you to sniff my hair old
man
blah blah no more blah blah